foreign
[Music]
to the 1900s we seemingly had a
perfectly good understanding of the laws
governing the physical Universe handed
down to us by the great Isaac Newton
these are the laws we still teach high
school kids around the world the laws of
so-called classical physics and for
those of you who like math here are some
of the essential equations but those are
details at the core of Newton's
perspective is the idea that if you
specify how the world is right now the
positions and velocities of all
ingredients and you specify the forces
acting on those ingredients the laws
predict how the world will be at any
subsequent moment the framework it's
it's Sleek it's elegant it's powerful
and it's rigid and it's determination of
the future and it worked the predictions
about the future were a pendulum would
be as it swung where a ball would land
when thrown where the moon would be in
its orbit around the Earth all of these
predictions and every other that was
made all of them were spot on accurate
that is until the early years of the
20th century when scientists gained the
capacity to explore the Micro World the
world of of molecules of atoms and
subatomic particles because in this
realm the predictions from Newton's math
were
they were wrong the data revealed that
new rules were needed to understand the
microscopic realm and remarkably within
just a few decades a generation of
scientists including the likes of Albert
Einstein
Max Planck Niels Bohr Werner Heisenberg
Erwin Schrodinger Max born and many
others this group of brilliant thinkers
ushered in a new understanding called
quantum mechanics now quantum mechanics
it comes with its own powerful
mathematical formulation but again one
can grasp the central new idea of
quantum mechanics even without the math
whereas Newton said
tell me how the world is now and I will
tell you how the world will be tomorrow
quantum mechanics says tell me how the
world is now and I'll tell you the
probability that the world will be one
way or the other tomorrow and according
to quantum mechanics
these probabilities provide the deepest
and most precise description of the
physical unfolding gone completely gone
according to Quantum Mechanics was the
rigid certainty of the classical world
now much has been made of Einstein's
resistance to the probabilistic nature
of quantum mechanics the famous and
frequently quoted God does not play dice
but Einstein did not deny that Quantum
probabilities provided a spectacularly
accurate description of the microscopic
realm instead he firmly believed that
quantum mechanics was only
a provisional Theory one that would
ultimately be replaced by a deeper
understanding that would not rely on
probabilities and toward this end
Einstein he worked tirelessly to expose
qualities of quantum mechanics that he
hoped would be so obviously unacceptable
so counter to any reasonable person's
expectation of how the world works that
everyone would have to agree with his
view that quantum mechanics was not the
final story and in 1935 with two
colleagues Boris Podolski and Nathan
Rosen Einstein believed he had finally
found the ultimate quantum mechanical
Achilles heel with a property inherent
to Quantum Mechanics called quantum
entanglement briefly put
Einstein and his colleagues found that
according to the math of quantum
mechanics if two objects interact and
then widely separate a subsequent
measurement on one of those objects
revealing one or another quality would
have an instantaneous influence on the
other object regardless of the distance
between them Einstein called this
strange Quantum connection he called it
spooky spooky action at a distance and
it troubled him deeply his his straight
forward intuitive belief was that widely
separated objects are independent of one
another but quantum entanglement
seemingly denied that by providing an
invisible Quantum connection capable of
linking the distant objects together or
as the name says entangling them
Einstein could not accept this Quantum
View of reality and so he concluded that
something had to give quantum mechanics
could not be the full and final story
that's the upshot of the 1935 so-called
epr paper now for years no one paid much
attention to the epr result mostly
because quantum mechanics worked and
moreover no one could see a way to test
Einstein's speculation that quantum
mechanics would one day be replaced by a
deeper understanding that would not need
probabilities
that is until 1964 when a physicist
named John Stewart Bell proved
mathematically that there was a way to
test Einstein's more conventional view
of reality that is to test his view that
particles always have definite features
and there's no spooky connections no
quantum entanglement
and this year's Nobel Prize in physics
has been awarded to Alana Spain John
clauser and Anton zeilinger whose
Collective Works have carried out that
test establishing to most people's
satisfaction Einstein's conventional
view of reality is rolled out that
quantum entanglement is real and more
than that have shown that quantum
mechanics and entanglement can be
leveraged for applications ranging from
Quantum Computing to quantum
teleportation
spectacular results that have both
changed our view of reality and whose
technological implications are both
exciting and profound
[Music]